I'm run left buttcheek model and scotch
punch over the years I've had more than
my fair share of success I can't
remember the last time I ate out of a
dumpster and I owe it all to my friends
well I might be good friends with the
Cable Guy nobodies friends with the
cable company and that's why I decided
to offer my new special a little
unprofessional as a direct download
through the internet for five bucks you
can download it watch it on the
television computer tablet smartphone
even your blender so then you duct tape
your smartphone to your blender or it
just won't work now here's a little
taste of what you're gonna be get we
flew in from Los Angeles and we're going
through LAX to go through screening and
this guy's just losing his [ __ ] mind
cuz I guess he doesn't travel that much
you're not used to this equipment and
he's just going crazy you know you can
have fun with that you can do what I do
I take two viagra and demand a pat-down
[Music]
what's that your pants mr. white and no
idea you're gonna need to Pat that down
pat it back up again give it a couple
twists see if it took to anything you
might want to go wash your hands after
you download the special it's yours to
watch it many times in well whenever you
are even in the most unprofessional
situations
[Music]
as an added bonus when you purchase the
special you'll automatically be entered
to win VIP tickets to my live show
they're right on that plane
David a so what are you waiting for
download the damn thing for yourself us
guys lining up to go knock you kid
and get a little ever especially with me
what's that advances
[Music]